7分文房具好きなんですけど掃除文法協会は最近止まっていますだふざけから後シャー
ペン
日本の者勉強会を大きく飛躍しアクアゲルらの国プリの腕が疲れないけれどが出ても
古いけどそもチェックさんにペン先が開店するクルトガ
グルドあり人気の掛けてはすごい日本のシャーペット技術は java
入ってくださっけど最近はちょっと for paris るん
わけじゃないんですよね10席回転数地点ですより先の技術があるかって言われたら
ん
なかなかそう簡単に出ないと思うんですよその中で最近発売したのがこちらのモード
クラブっていう
喋っもどって知ってますよね孫に使ってるやって仕事です
水を使っていると思います
やけに折れますよね決してたすっごいこぼれませんっていう
削らどんなものなんでしょうね
回してくださいまま消し込む
デイ出図させず
まああのなんだろば新作ですよ
小さくなで買ってるんですけどたローニャ変化はないですね
文房具業界はちょっとまだしばらく
大きな進歩はないと思いますくるとがー
次のテクニック次のキッズが出るにはまだ時間がかかりそうですね
なんかで結構カラーバリエーションが多かったですなんか黄緑買ったんですけどなんか
ね苦労とかあたんとかいろいろあったんで
ぜひ探してみてください
おおおおおお
おかっけーなー各界各界のでかっこいいいい
俺のほうでピンターからどうすればいいんだろういない方がいい
一応こんな感じですね駄目ここがでこうまましたらこれがましたら消しゴムが出るん
ですよ
これがもう決してだから折れやすいじゃなくて書きやすい
じゃなくて今日しやすい的な
あれなんだと思います小学校へグリップあでもこれって言いたくなりそうだなぁ
ダークリップじゃないかちょっと痛くなるかもしれませんが透明なんでまぁかっこいい
ですね
楽園先結構と買ってるんでイラスト書いたり製図用とかに向いてるサーフィンな気がし
ますあんまりこう長い時間かけようなタイプじゃないですね
正確さを追求したシャーペンに分類されると思います
開ければこれちょっと変えてみましょうどっかここでできるのが本当にいいですね
こういう
を
書きやすいこれはいいですよいやーいいですねこれ書きやすいです
やっぱ製図用だからペン先とかっているから書きやすいですねこういうペンはあなた
ぶん蔵でギアとか
ステッドラーとかそれ好きな人はすごい気に入るかと思いますマニアックな話ですい
ません
グラ有起哉とか s 3とか亜星強細いシャーペン式な人は絶対気に入ると思うので
是非
買ってみたらいいと思います
どうフェラーああ
dan
dea